[Music]
research shows that living in the midst
of high conflict relationships can
actually damage your health shorten your
lifespan and it can even make an Brain
Age faster so how can you fix a
relationship when it's going wrong
[Music]
talking about it at an early stage but
talking about it when you're calm you
know so actually setting aside some time
where you're not going to have
distractions and you can talk to the
other person but in ER just quite a
neutral kind of pragmatics how are we
going to sort this out kind of away I
think the longer you try and bottle it
up the more it comes out is like a
snippy comment here and there it's
something's wrong with something annoys
you bring it up sooner rather than later
if there are difficulties around your
sex life remember this in a committed
monogamous relationship you're the only
other person who can give that to your
partner so it's really imperative that
you do both find a happy medium that
satisfies both of you the couples that
have been together for a longer period
and they talked about the fact that the
relationships just not as passionate as
it was but that wasn't an issue for them
so the people who had a good sex life it
seemed to be like an added bonus they
were strongly attracted to each other
sex was a good connection for them but
it was an additional benefit on top of
the friendship and the companionship be
honest with each other about what you
need in the bedroom be proactive and
really take your time to work at it
because it may not happen overnight but
you do want to reach a point where
you're both satisfied do we actually
have a good friendship that's going to
last the course you know it's not just
that I'm attracted to this person but
actually we have enough in common that
you know in 3040 years time if we've had
kids and they've left home we're still
going to enjoy each other's company I
think we definitely have a foundation of
friendship
I mean we've mostly hang out with each
other's if you didn't like burning don't
each other heads probably they'll be but
I'll say you're my best friend
the longer you're going out with someone
the more of a confidant they become and
the more ya you open up about things you
wouldn't even open up to like yeah your
best mates about what's the question
one lady told me I wasn't expecting it
to be Cinderella and roses or every day
and so they were disappointed because
their expectations were quite realistic
in the first place we had to decide very
quickly cuz I'm from an Indian family
who didn't necessarily approve of me
dating a white person like it's all fine
now it did mean we had to kind of decide
very early on how committed we were cuz
it's not easy it's normal to have fights
that doesn't mean that it's the end of
the relationship so instead of their
kind of either the Disney stories or the
Photoshop lives of celebrities actually
real life isn't like that and sometimes
you've got to get your head down and
you've got to work at it appreciation
and not becoming complacent is so
important at the end of the day doesn't
matter if you've been together for a few
years or you've been married for 30 the
fact that that person's choosing to be
with you is massive so always appreciate
them and their presence in your life and
all that they bring to it and the more
you appreciate them and show it the more
they'll do for you well you're very
intelligent incredibly determined she's
just a very kind nice generous person
you should write these things on post-it
notes and just leave them around the
house whilst positive relationships are
really important for our health negative
relationships are really bad for our
house so it's so important to know when
to draw the line and walk away now it
may be that one of you wants to work on
the relationship and the other one
doesn't and if one of you is motivated
but both of you are not it's not going
to work
on the other hand if you're in a
mentally or physically abusive
relationship for example then you have
to own your own worth and know that you
deserve so much better than that you
have to be able to walk away to protect
your own mental health and well-being
not just now but in your future as well